j'attendais de cette émission de la
sincérité et puis des solutions pour la
france et je n'ai rien eu de tout cela
voilà ni l'un ni l'autre j'avais envie
c'était le titre de l'émission qu'on me
dise où aller la france est en fait j'ai
entendu parler que des manuels macron
donc on a un président et je crois que
c'était très clair dans l'émission il
n'a pas réformé il ne réformera plus les
français nous ont fait confiance les
français lui ont donné sa chance il l'a
pas saisie c'est parce qu'il a des liens
il a plutôt défendu ce qu'il avait
réformé et commencent à évoquer la
réforme des retraites concrètement ben
oui celle qui l'a pas fait et sait qu'il
ne fera donc pas d'ici d'ici la fin de
son quinquennat donc en fait donné 50
plus emmanuel macron c-50 trop cédé 5
ans sans rien changer à la vie des
français emmanuel macron nous emmène
dans un mur de dette et de déficit 2800
milliards de dettes mille milliards de
dettes de plus sur la tête des français
hier bart avec ça ya dix ans on rit mais
attendez on est devant un mur de dette
moi je veux sortir de cette impasse et
je veux surtout que les français
puissent vivre dignement de leur salaire
et de leurs retraites et ça suppose quoi
ça suppose de baisser les charges sur
les salaires pour baisser ses charges
faut bien que je trouve l'argent avec
2800 milliards de dettes mais nan mais
c'est important madame lapix train avec
2800 milliards de dettes il faut trouver
l'argent l'argent on ne le trouvera que
si on dépense mieux et si on supprime
une bonne partie de cette couche de
bureaucratie